miss plana how are you
i'm great let's get after it today
somebody in the chat said that you look
a lot more rested today that's because
you got eight hours i did get eight
hours all right what do you got for us
christine lagarde yes
so christine lagarde is the european
central bank president and she thinks
cryptocurrencies
are worth nothing
she said she thinks crypto should be
regulated to protect inexperienced
investors and her comment her comments
come at an interesting time
because she is also thinking about
ending ecb's negative interest rates in
europe there's a lot to unpack here the
first thing i'm going to say
the first thing that you say is it's
worthless well if it's worthless then
just put it to the side and don't worry
about it right but they say no it's
worthless and we need to regulate it if
it has no value why do you need to
regulate it doesn't make a lot of sense
now their argument will be oh it is so
worthless it is so dangerous
that we need to prevent people from
actually going ahead and buying this
but they don't say that because that
would mean that they would have to
outlaw it or make it illegal if you
actually want to prevent people from
buying something there are tools in your
toolbox as a government don't give them
ideas make it illegal no go ahead make
it illegal now they're not going to do
that why because all get voted out of
office is politicians central bankers
are not elected officials they are
appointed officials and therefore they
cannot make laws they cannot do that so
their next best tool in their toolbox is
to say well we can't make it illegal so
what we're going to do instead is we're
going to try to regulate it but oh by
the way it is worthless makes zero sense
now what i actually think is true is
they understand that there is a lot of
value here not only do they understand
that there's value they see this
competition it is free market
competition if you're a central bank you
are given the responsibility but also
the power to control
create and distribute a currency now all
of a sudden there is a decentralized
free market competition that seems to be
getting quite a bit of attention and
there's estimated to be 150 million
people who actually hold bitcoin and so
naturally if you don't like that what do
you say it's worthless but we need to
regulate it this is all a sleight of
hand now the one other thing that i'll
say very quickly
is that
she along with other central bankers
around the world they got their hands
full they they're like uh jugglers at
the circus right now like
crypto worthless crypto regulated oh
macro environment changing negative
rates this and they're sitting there
just juggling all this stuff right are
you calling her a clown but i'm not
saying that she's a clown no look she's
incredibly intelligent and anyone who
thinks that these people are not
intelligent you are just uh uh losing
the plot these people are incredibly
intelligent that's how they get to the
position that they are
now the ecb has had negative interest
rates for eight nine years
they historically have said we were
going to stick to negative interest
rates we're gonna stick to negative
interest rates even when the market
turned over in november and it's been
falling and the federal reserve said we
are going to start increasing our
interest rates we're gonna make capital
more expensive in the market the ecb
said we don't care what our peers do we
are going to stick with our plan
hello capitulation this morning bam
changing our mind now they're going to
go from negative interest rates to zero
and probably from zero to positive which
means that they now are getting on board
with the fed's plan which means every
central bank in the world they're all
about to start to increase the cost of
capital which means asset prices of
certain types of assets are going to
continue to fall yeah it's really
interesting because they change their
mind all the time and they change
strategies and tactics all the time so
if you were to actually listen to what
they said they were going to do
do you know why this is a perfect
example of the difference between this
and uh bitcoin why because bitcoin's got
a programmatic monetary policy don't
give a [ __ ] what's happened in the world
tsunami don't care hurricane don't care
pandemic don't care uh price is going up
don't care price is going down don't
care it's software just
you always know bitcoin stance it's
programmatic they are not programmatic
they have a fun fact about christine
lagarde if you want to hear it go ahead
what do you got for me so christine
lagarde in the interview obviously she
said that she want she does not own any
crypto she said i want to practice what
i preach however
however she has two sons one of them
he he's got digital assets in his
portfolio it looks like so she said hey
he's a free man oh shocking shocking her
son is okay to do what he wants but
let's regulate all the common people
well i mean her son would be included
i'm guessing oh let me teach you how
they make rules sometimes a lot of times
they make the rules and they say you
guys all have to follow the rules but
family and friends
different set of rules go ahead what's
next spacex spacex is raising a massive
round of fresh funding sending the
private company's valuation to mars no
to about 127 billion dollars the space
venture is looking to bring in up to
1.725 billion new capital at a price of
70 per share underpriced
wow okay i can't even understand these
numbers are insane 125 billion seven
127 billion 127 billion under
undervalued because you think spacex can
be a trillion dollar company i don't
know 127 billion is a lot that's like
well okay hold on a second
name another company
yeah that gets somebody from earth to
iss
i have a question
there ain't no other company that can do
that in the world i have a question
spacex tesla all these companies are
very very very dependent on elon musk is
there not key man risky oh there's
definitely keyman insurance someone
making a bag on key man insurance of
elixir because i'm elon yeah that he
he's probably the single most important
entrepreneur of our lifetime i guess
people thought that about steve jobs and
here we are with tim cook think apple's
doing just fine no here we are apple no
you're proving the point
name the last product that apple
invented
watch no airpods airpods airpods no yeah
that's that's a new pro those are new
products would that come out a decade
ago no
look and see when did airpods get
invented literally in the last five
years when you take the founder the
innovator out of a company
bad [ __ ] happens when were airpods
created
they were created in 2016. that's six
years ago okay six years ago so in six
years
they invented nothing no they have every
year they have a thing
matt can attest what did they do
there's like tvs and stuff
steve jobs died in 2011 the newest thing
that these people created was literally
headphones without a cord no
that's what they did they literally just
cut the cord off of the headphones hold
on okay
okay the third generation
iphone sc with 5g and a chip and this is
an evolution that's not that's not
disruptive innovation when steve jobs
got his ass up on that uh stage and he
said the iphone the world changed
forever so here's let's go back to now
you're all talking about let's go back
to spacex 127 billion all hinging on one
man no it's not on one man if elon
here's my prediction if elon literally
tomorrow just said hey i've never talked
to anyone in spacex again i don't think
that it would be as successful as it
will be with him
but i think that the business would not
go away yeah gwen shot well who's the
president of uh spacex president right i
believe she's president she runs
let's go let's go the other thing that
i'll say too is that a lot of people
think of space as sending people there
one of the big parts of spacex's
business is now that they have the
ability to have the reusable rockets
it's pretty um frequent that they're
actually launching recovering
relaunching etc uh they'll put a lot of
satellites still i think key man risk is
a big one correct you're surprised i
knew that didn't you okay next
okay hyundai i think that's how you
pronounce it hyundai like sunday
somebody told me that in the comments
once hyundai plans 5 billion investment
in u.s on mobility technology such as
autonomous driving and robotics hyundai
nobody's catching tesla nobody is
catching tesla
okay but why not try
of course they have to for second place
or third place for eighth place well
just to be a car company in the future
you're going to have to have autonomous
driving but nobody is going to catch
tesla because it's a data game and they
have more data i think hyundai is smart
because instead of like licensing or
paying tesla for its technology in the
future they're trying to develop their
own yeah you got to play catch up
absolutely but i just think that when i
see these announcements this is a
defensive move this is not an offensive
move what would be an offensive move for
hyundai
at this point i don't think that they
have an offensive move
unless literally they said how do we get
enough money to buy tesla but they don't
have enough money oh god right but like
there is no offensive move because if
you're not the innovator you're always
playing defense you're always playing
catch up
again hyundai great company
not the innovator in this vertical
people are saying you love elon
i love elon because elon is a example
not the only example a example
of somebody who thinks from first
principle stan uh standpoint and solves
hard problems
and then does it from an innovation
standpoint
elon musk one of my favorite stories
about elon musk is that elon literally
was in vegas while all of his friends
were partying in the uh i think it's
ashley vance uh i think is the one who
wrote the book on elon
he's reading books about rockets
and the whole point was he said i need
to go buy a rocket and he went to russia
to go buy a rocket and so it's just like
how many people would have been like he
caught himself rocket science i wonder
if we could launch a rocket and then
get it back and then use it again i feel
like probably a lot of people but some
of them don't have the funding okay so
we watched a great movie this weekend
called the boy who harnessed the wind
yeah fans have seen it great movie it's
on netflix it's about a boy in africa
there was a famine slash
because
uh there was no water it was a whole
thing anyway he engineered the problem
but what are the chances of a kid like
that being the elon of you know being
born somewhere else where he doesn't
have that elon was born in south africa
i understand but not like you know in
that kind of situation and
listen you can solve a problem with a
little bit of information some hard work
that's what ends up happening so the
reason why by the way there's
many people like elon to your point they
don't have access to funding they don't
have the ability to go big like all
these different things but i think that
those people i think the builders the
innovators of society those people are
way more important than we have put uh
the importance on them over the last
couple of years and it's become cool to
hate on the tech industry to hate on
this they hate on that well guess what
while you're hating on the tech industry
you're literally using the products that
the tech industry created
where'd you write your hate at oh did
you write it on twitter did you write it
on facebook did you use your ipad did
you yeah did you use your iphone oh what
did you do oh you went you used cloud
storage at amazon
like yeah tech industry they really suck
what did you fire off that mean tweet in
between the times where you pressed a
button and uber eats brought you some
food i have a hot take go ahead i think
in the last several decades
it's become i think i think maybe steve
jobs was the first to become like a
celebrity ceo
and then from there
people are treating the tech industry
how hollywood
how like media organizations treat
hollywood in terms of like ooh celebrity
let's talk about their love life let's
talk about their like personal life it
has moved beyond just the technology
just them as an operator i understand
the argument of like hey these are the
people who end up creating these
products we want to know who they are
what's going on in their life i i get it
but my point is just that we need the
counterweight there's been this huge
rise of hate on the tech industry tech
is bad all these people are uh bros and
blue all the stuff right we need the
counterweight which says no these people
are fundamentally changing the world and
i look we have a daughter i want our
daughter to grow up to be just like them
and the reason why i want that is is
because i want our daughter to
understand when there's a problem you
can use your brain you can go get
information you can think from first
principles you can solve the problem and
my guess is that society would be
drastically off
better by having every child emulate the
problem solvers and entrepreneurs of our
society rather than go shake their asses
on [ __ ] tick tock
and how do you avoid like hero worship
or the fact that like a lot of things
may fail even if you do everything right
people will always find heroes
it's literally built into our dna right
and so guess what you can worship the
problem solvers and the builders or the
kim kardashians or the people twerking
on the internet
but you gotta you're gonna end up
worshiping somebody
yeah
or and so the people who are yelling and
screaming about oh the builders the
builders the builders those are bad
people whatever ask them who they
worship the socialist
is that like who who else are you going
to go and support i think there's a
difference between worshiping idolizing
and learning from right i don't i don't
want our daughter for example to worship
anybody i think it's more about like how
what what are the pieces i can take from
these respect you can it's all
interchangeable you can use the word
respect right uh and say we respect
these people because of what they've
been able to do right but the problem is
that the same person will go and attack
these uh you know the billionaires are
so bad right they'll then turn around
and they'll literally be like oh look at
this only fan star
right or they'll sit at home for 17
hours over the weekend and they'll
literally just infest their mind with
nonsense on reality television hey
i can say that because sometimes my wife
all right what's next okay next
starbucks will exit russia after 15
years closing 130 license cafes i have a
question for you what percentage do you
think the russian market is responsible
for in starbucks's revenue
that was a very long eight percent
no what how much one percent one percent
oh yeah
i thought it was massive i thought it
would be
all right next sports wait hold on but
no oh we just gotta hurry but no we
don't we have five minutes no no we
gotta hurry why
because the timer is a little off we
gotta you're off
okay
so
so
so is this is this not crazy i mean like
i don't know in the whole russia
situation anyway we can move on i just
thought no comments okay sports all
right prices are surging but fans are
still paying top dollar to watch live
sports guys there's inflation the is
there is there is there the thing yeah
is there an exclamation point yes thank
you guys for including the exclamation
point in sports so
so sports uh what is going on
inflation is hitting sports people are
paying so much money to go watch live
sports sports immune to inflation ticket
prices for upcoming 2022
nfl games were averaging 307
immediately following the release of
league schedule
non-story inflation affects every single
industry there's no industry as well
people were willing to pay this at this
pga championship 18 beers you were
willing to shell out money that's not
even that expensive 18 for a beer have
you ever gone to a sporting event it's
always expensive like on a relative
basis would it go up two dollars it used
to be 16 out of 18 like i love a good 10
hot dog
i will pay whatever for those hot dogs
what's next
why are you rushing me through my topics
this is an important one
ready yes why are you looking at me like
that come on why is he looking at me
like that
okay um it's ask lunch money time
claudio porquez
asks he has two questions first did the
leonidas statue find a new home
no it's just chilling don't worry about
my statues i for those that don't know i
have about a i don't know god i wish i'd
provided a photo two foot maybe uh tall
leonidas statue and he has a spear and
the spear one time clinton walked by it
and got stabbed with it and i told her
don't be messing with my statues luke
said you were annoyed with me are you
annoyed with me no i'm not annoyed with
you but we just we have a schedule now
we gotta stick on the schedule
11 20 11 20. what are you talking oh
okay okay final question will kevin
o'leary invite pomp to the shark tank
someday i don't want to go on shark tank
oh god no i'm cool i like them and
everything but that's just not mine all
right friends i'm being rushed out
security's in here but you forgot uh one
more thing what ftx is our sponsor ftx
us this whole episode is sponsored by
ftx ftx has two things that you should
know about one they have amazing pricing
in terms of if you go and use buy
bitcoin or other assets uh they have
some of the best pricing in the market
uh and then two is they just launched
the beta for stocks but there's no
commissions and also there's no payment
for order flow so if you're into bitcoin
cryptocurrencies stocks etc go download
ftx us if you're in the us go get ftx us
uh and you can click on the link in the
description and you'll be able to
download that and they'll give you a
bunch of stuff uh when you download it
and you just begin trading on ftx stx a
great brand
obviously great brand us
perfect combination thank you
love you all thank you so much paulina
thank you
for being rushed out i've never had this
if you don't stick to the schedule i'm
going to keep this party moving
all right thank you hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time